so we're going to begin we're going to
be with the chronovirus the u.s has now
surpassed
11 million coronavirus cases as
hospitals are pushed to the breaking
point
it took just one week for the u.s to go
from 10 million to 11 million confirmed
cases
consider that that is more cases in
seven days here in the united states
than all but nine countries have seen in
total worldwide
hospitalizations are also at the highest
numbers since the crisis began and 48
states have reported an
increase in average daily
hospitalizations over the past week
today at least four states are
implementing new coronavirus
restrictions
the city of chicago is also imposing a
stay-at-home advisory but just this
morning
we learned some very encouraging news
modernist says preliminary results show
its phase 3 vaccine
is 94 and a half percent effective in
trials last time i checked 94 is a
really good score
this comes after pfizer said last week
that its vaccine was more than
90 percent effective joining us now is a
member of the president-elect joe
biden's new coronavirus advisory board
michael osterholm he's an epidemiologist
and director of the center for
infectious
disease research and policy at the
university of minnesota first on cbs
this morning
he's announcing a new fund to help
families of frontline health care
workers
who have lost their lives to covet 19.
mr osama i'll get to that in just a
second welcome thanks for being with us
but i
i want to start you've said that this is
the most dangerous time
since 1918 the pandemic of 1918
where is this trend line taking us and
what do we have to do
immediately to get this under control
well first of all the great news is what
we heard today from moderna and the fact
that we have a vaccine that not only
prevented illnesses but evidence of
severe illnesses
so we have to imagine that we're going
to a day and
hopefully in the months ahead where this
will be behind us but right now
we are in the most dangerous period as
you noted
you know what the numbers are right now
and what we call exponential growth
where the case numbers are literally
doubling
every few days and i think between now
and
well and past the holidays we are going
to see a major increase in in cases in
this country and
many parts of the world you've spoken to
a handful of governors what have you
recommended they do
well i think all governors right now are
just looking for what to do they want to
base it on science they have to
they understand the economy we are
really at a disadvantage because if
we're going to ask people to suffer for
this
from an economic standpoint meaning
shutting down their businesses
people being unemployed city governments
state governments no longer able to fund
many of the very essential workers fire
police we need economic support to take
care of that if we're going to also take
care of the pandemic
and so until we get that it's going to
be a real challenge for governors to do
anything
that doesn't cause great conflict within
their communities
should there be a uniform national
response do you believe and if so what
should that look like
well clearly each and every area of the
country has a little bit different
picture on what's happening meaning
in some cases the transmission is more
in the communities of color in other
areas in rural
america it's not but what we need to do
is have a standard set of principles
what are we trying to do
we're trying to get ourselves through
this period to a time when vaccine
will end this pandemic as we know it and
right now we don't have a standardized
set so what you're hearing is
all these governors and mayors are
scrambling to try to find
what is the right answer for us and it
would surely help all of them and that's
what i'm hearing from them
if we had a standardized set of of
recommendations and protocols
as we mentioned you're launching a new
fund with the saint paul and minnesota
foundation
to support families of health care
workers uh who died of coven 19. tell us
about what you're doing
well you know we have witnessed over the
course of this pandemic the most
horrible tragic pain
of watching healthcare workers
themselves become patients and dying
over 1400 healthcare workers in this
country have died from covet 19.
not all of them of course from work but
many and it has disproportionately
affected our communities of color
and you know they've been there for us
they've been there to take care of us
we can't make it right what's happened
but we can do something about that so
this fund is to help the families
it's to help the children we're going to
be offering college scholarships to all
the children
of these fallen heroes and so what we're
hoping today is that america
understands the major sacrifice these
families have made
will all get to behind us here and
support these families
in a way that it's the least we can do
for what they've done for us
it sure is and they continue to
sacrifice for us michael osterhome
thank you so much for more information
on the fund to help families of health
care workers visit
frontlinefamiliesfund.org